do we weigh the same everywhere so when  you stand on the weighing machine and it  shows your particular weight does that  mean that you will weigh the same in any  other part of the planet well the answer  might surprise you so the Earth is  slightly flattened at the pores and  pulches of the Equator because of the  speed of its rotation right so the  gravitational force on the pole again is  slightly more and the moles as compared  to the Equator so there will be a  minuscule difference in your field if  you are the pole as compared to the  equator fascinating isn't it now there  are other celestial bodies where our  weights would vary a lot for instance if  you're on the moon you will weigh 1 6 of  what you would actually wear on Earth  and do you know on Jupiter you will wear  2.5 times as that much as you weigh on  the earth now can you tell me why answer  down in the comments below and for more  such fascinating videos follow don't  memorize And subscribe to our Channel